el ambiente es de mucha alegría hay
caravanas una verdadera marea roja que
está
tomando el centro de Brasilia en
dirección a la Explanada de los
ministerios a la plaza de los tres
poderes donde se realizará de aquí a
poco la investidura de Lula sobre la
seguridad hemos visto en esos días Mucha
policía muchas fuerzas especiales
entrevistamos a la subsecretaria de
seguridad del DF del Distrito Federal
donde está Brasilia y nos dijo que han
reforzado todos los puntos más sensibles
como los hoteles donde están los jefes
de Estados extranjeros y los
diplomáticos torre de televisión por
supuesto aeropuerto y las principales
carreteras podéis seguir en este momento
el rudo de un helicóptero ha habido
muchos helicópteros esos días
sobrevolando la zona de momento nos
aseguran desde la Secretaría de
Seguridad que va a salir todo bien bueno
Valeria Esperemos que así sea pero
hablemos ahora de la ausencia de
bolsonaro porque el presidente saliente
a Estados Unidos y dice que no le pondrá
la banda presidencial a Lula su
principal rival que se espera entonces
de cómo sea la toma de Posesión y sobre
todo con la posible llegada de
presidentes invitados como Nicolás
Maduro
Esa es la gran pregunta que se hace todo
Brasil Quién va a pasar la banda
presidencial a Lola tradicionalmente es
un acto protocolario de cortesía de
celebración de una alternancia
democrática sin embargo Jair bolsonaro
dijo en varias ocasiones que él no
respetaría este Rito que tenemos que
decir también no es obligatorio pero
todos los presidentes de la red
democratización lo han hecho hasta ahora
también hay otra cuestión a lo mejor por
primera vez vamos a ver un un perrito
subir la rampa presidencial se llama
resistencia es el perrito que acompañó a
Lula durante sus 580 días de reclusión
incurritiva estaba en el campamento de
sus seguidores debajo de la prisión
cuando se enfermó su actual esposa le
adoptó y parece que este perrito
resistencia va a subir la rampa junto a
la pareja a Lula y allancha para
recordar la resistencia de Lula en la
cárcel y Qué se sabe de la posible
llegada de maduro
sobre Maduro sabemos que existía desde
2019 una ordenanza que prohibía la
entrada de cualquier representante del
gobierno venezolano a Brasil para Lula
era muy importante tener en su posesión
a todos los líderes de América Latina
porque él quiere impulsar a esta Unión
latinoamericana finalmente de forma
sorpresiva pocas horas antes de ir a
Estados Unidos bolsonaro revocó
oficialmente esta ordenanza entonces en
teoría maduro podría venir Pero hay una
serie de impedimentos Como por ejemplo
las sanciones que el gobierno de los
Estados Unidos aplica cualquier empresa
que trate con el gobierno de maduro
Entonces hasta ahora no se sabe todavía
si va a poder llegar el presidente de
Venezuela a la posesión de